today we're going to talk about a
nutrient called benfotiamine and this is
a synthetic b1 b1 is naturally water
Seibel this is a fat-soluble b1 and yes
it is made synthetically but this is one
of the only synthetic vitamins that I
would recommend because it has virtually
no side effects and I believe every
single diabetic should be taking
benfotiamine and here's why because
vitamin b1 is intimately involved in the
little mini engine in your mitochondria
that involves the glucose metabolism and
the more glucose that you have running
through that machine the higher the
blood sugar the more depleted of b1
you're going to become and with
diabetics there's four main tissues that
are involved the nerves and brain the
eyes the kidney and the heart vessels
and it just so happens that benfotiamine
can help you with each one of them now
because benfotiamine is fat soluble it
can penetrate 3 to 5 times deeper into
the nerves in your brain and it can
really create some really cool effects
its main function is it protects against
oxidation and this is really that the
problem with diabetes you have so much
glucose involved that the amount of
oxidation is so high you're getting all
sorts of free radical damage you're
getting complications all the tissues
start breaking down simply because of
the oxidation of glucose well any type
of b1 will counter that but benfotiamine
goes a little bit deeper benfotiamine
will also reduce advanced glycation
end-products now what is that when you
combine glucose with the protein or
glucose with the fat under heat you
start creating these these sticky
proteins now your body can make these or
you can consume them in certain foods so
if you took like barbecued ribs for
example where they are cooking this
sugar with meat or even ice cream where
you have a lot of sugar you have the
milk protein and fat all cooked up
that's going to give you a lot of these
and this will basically
add more oxidation accelerate the aging
process create a lot of sticky proteins
that get stuck in your arteries your
brain your eyes and it creates a lot of
other issues benfotiamine can also
decrease your a1c as well now the main
way that I used it when I was in
practice is for peripheral neuropathy
and that's a condition where you have a
breakdown the nervous system in your
feet or your fingertips so you might
have pain in your feet or numbness or
burning pain making you difficult to
walk this stuff works like magic you'd
want to take at least 600 milligrams per
day and you can spread it out I don't
have any specific benfotiamine to
recommend you're gonna have to do your
own research to find something that
maybe has some good reviews but if
you're a diabetic and you have feet pain
this will work like magic so it's really
good for restoring nerve function it's
good for pain it's good for any type of
neuropathies and it's also good to
protect the brain against diabetic
complications because a lot of times a
diabetic will have dementia to have
memory loss I mean type 3 diabetes is
Alzheimer's so it can actually help that
condition greatly now as far as the eyes
go there's a lot of secondary
complications from diabetes concerning
the eye and one is damage to the retina
well guess what the retina is all nerve
tissue so benfotiamine is really good
for the retina to protect against damage
it's also good to protect against the
kidney cell called a nephron so if
someone has kidney damage let's say they
have stage three or four even five this
is something I would highly recommend
then we have the heart in the heart
vessels there's a certain layer on the
inside of the artery called the
epithelial layer and the microvascular
the tiny little blood vessels that
innervate that can be protected when you
take benefit Amin in fact if you're
deficient in B one of Miss important
antioxidant and you can develop damage
dysfunction and then guess what
cholesterol builds up
calcium builds up and you start getting
plaque in the arteries so benfotiamine
is very very important in cardiovascular
function and act to protect the arteries
and of course I'm assuming that you're a
regular viewer because if you're not I'm
also gonna recommend healthy keto okay
and in a minute fasting as the basic
diet that you need to do in addition to
this because if you're doing this
without correcting the diet it might not
work as well I put a link down below
for more information about that thanks
for watching so if you want more
knowledge on how to create a healthy
body subscribe now and get daily
notifications